we welcome you back to CBS mornings we
continue our special series we call it
crime without punishment looking at the
disturbing rise in unsolved murder cases
in this country we've shown why some big
city police departments cannot keep Pace
with a rising number of killings and how
it has made the families of the murder
victims very frustrated and very angry
this morning we look at a potential
solution of federal state and local
partnership that could be we say could
be a model for other cities Chief
investigative correspondent that's Jim
Axelrod went to Baltimore to learn
exactly how it works they have some
history in doing this kind of thing they
do good morning good morning to you what
we kept hearing from police chief after
police chief detective after detective
in our collaborative investigation done
by CBS News and local CBS stations
around the country were descriptions of
a crippling shortage of Manpower and
resources in Baltimore we found an
approach that seems to be gaining some
Traction in addressing these shortages
in solving more murders
teamwork
his career was standing on that end so
far this week we've documented a
troubling trend for people getting away
with murder the rate of making arrests
in murder cases is at a 50-year low
Baltimore Police are pleading for help
as they work to solve 16 shootings and
28 armed robberies Baltimore is no
different where police solve less than
half of the homicides except here plenty
of room big space they just might be
finding a solution to this disturbing
problem there it is
it's an approach overseen by Eric Barron
the U.S attorney in Maryland Baron hopes
to boost the rate of homicide arrests
with more intelligence developed from a
partnership housed in a nondescript
Warehouse in a secured location we've
been asked to conceal this is the
organized crime drug enforcement task
force warning you had a couple of search
warrants you did a strike force of local
and federal authorities taking aim at
Baltimore's violent crime the law
enforcement Community is so balkanized
you got local state federal here is
where we can put all or most of them
together in one place sharing
information working together 16 people
you heard that right shot over the
weekend alone we visited after a violent
Father's Day weekend added six new
homicides to the city's totem so this is
a map that we generated of all the
homicides and shootings in 2021 in
Baltimore City intelligence analyst
there Billy Nichols is the dot connector
in Chief here at least 338 homicides in
red last year alone they are in every
part every portion of the city each
morning Nichols opens an email with
what's called a 24 a fresh report of
each homicide shooting and questionable
death in the city in the last 24 hours
the first thing I'm looking for is
really to see whether or not our victim
has anything to do with any of our cases
because you know if if that's the case
then it seems The Logical thought would
be it has something to do with the
ongoing investigation Nichols worked the
streets for more than 20 years as a
Baltimore Police Officer so you might
get something in a 24
that connects up to another homicide
investigation
or another Federal you know federal
investigation Triple C was as organized
and Savvy as they are violent and
Relentless the idea is to build big
cases that take lots of murderers off
the street at once like the 15 Triple C
gang members linked to 18 homicides and
27 other attempts they were indicted
last summer on drug racketeering and
conspiracy charges this business was
built on violence murders and shootings
of rival gang members and drug dealers
John lensner was the acting U.S attorney
in Baltimore at the time a one
indictment can not only lead to Violent
gang members serving in prison but can
also help a city clear a number of
homicides that have gone unsolved for a
number of years Eric Barron the current
U.S attorney calls it the Al Capone
strategy the violent mob boss wasn't
busted for murder in the 1930s he was
convicted on tax evasion charges the
problem is a 50-year low in clearing
murder cases the solution if I hear you
right is cooperation absolutely it's the
biggest part of the solution cooperation
not just among law enforcement but the
community as well
it all boils down to teamwork it seems
yeah you know and after demonstrating
the extent of this problem for a couple
days it's refreshing to hear somebody
talking about Solutions why do they want
to keep the location a secret I think
there is such pressure first of all to
find something the Department of Justice
overseeing this always cautious by
Nature wants to make sure nothing gets
in the way by way of uh contamination or
compromise and there has been some
issues in years past with the BPD right
it was some corruption that that was a
big story Nationwide and that speaks to
what we found in all cities yes which is
it that compromises the relationship
between police and community and without
that cooperation you have an issue so to
restore the trust that's been eroded
everyone we talked through the entire
investigation says that is the key
Community Police restoration of trust
is the answer to reducing this
disturbing Trend your stories yesterday
were so heartbreaking this week you know
where mothers are asked to solve their
own crimes it's nice to see that there
is some solution that could possibly
work right yeah also nice to see us
doing this kind of a project exactly
working with our stations across the
country exactly right yeah broadreach
yeah absolutely Jim thank you nice to
sit with you great to be good morning
good to see you all right